one of the central themes that's running
throughout all of Wollstonecraft's
vindication of the rights of women and
really a lot of her other works as well
is this notion that inequality is a
central problem for modern civilized
society and it has to be dealt with
in order to deal with it it has to be
identified as such and we have to think
about how its generated how its
perpetuated
yeah and how it might be addressed and
so she's providing answers to all of
those she's also taking on people like
John Jacques Rousseau and saying that
although their analysis was correct in
certain respects it's fundamentally
wrong in other respects and then it's
left out some vital things from the
picture namely the inequality that's
been imposed upon women now what I want
to start with is actually her her
critique Rousseau and building off of
that she's got this great passage where
she says Rousseau exerts himself to
prove that all was right originally a
crowd of authors that all is now right
and I that all will be right so she's
saying Rousseau is saying what the past
was right but the present is screwed up
a lot of people are saying that the
present is just great couldn't be any
better
I'm saying no the president screwed up
the past is screwed up the future is
where things are going to be right if we
actually set them right so what does it
take for that to happen well in order to
answer that first we have to see how we
got from the past to the future and
Rousseau tells a kind of story about
this that that Wollstonecraft is going
to consider and say yeah it's right in
certain respects but also fundamentally
wrong in other respects so we're so
begins with this this state of nature in
which human beings are essentially
solitary undeveloped beings and
eventually they start to form societies
they do so he's got a whole long you
know
discussion about how this occurs and you
can see this in some of the other videos
I don't need to rehearse this here but
they arrive in a stage of primitive
society the kind of societies that we
see our ancient ancestors creating you
know Rousseau uses Sparta as an example
you know in those societies there are
going to be inequalities inequalities of
a couple different forms there's
inequalities of personal merit some
people are better than others sometimes
it's personal merit in terms of who can
run the fastest or who can you know hunt
the best or it could be in terms of you
know moral qualities who has the most
self-control who has the strongest
developed sense of justice who is the
most courageous but there's inequalities
as well of three other key things one of
them is wealth whatever ends up being
property for that society ends up
functioning as a kind of exchange but
also a marker that indicates to people
who matters who can buy who can purchase
who can exchange and and wealth tends to
substitute for the other sorts of
inequalities Rousseau says those other
inequalities are power or authority so
imagine when somebody's placed over
somebody else could be in a family where
one person is is in charge and the other
people have to obey them could be in a
workshop could be in terms of political
authority could be a hunting party where
somebody's calling the shots somebody's
put in charge and then another
distinction is nobility or rank so
people are felt to be better blood or
quality they're they're somehow
distinguished from the others in terms
of rank you know these can you know
these can actually be quite jarring with
each other you know wealth can compete
with rank as we see it happen a lot of
ancient societies but whole there's
inequalities there Rousseau thinks that
human beings are actually better human
beings in a state of primitive society
there
she's put over here there are the best
human beings in the state of nature but
in primitive societies are still pretty
good they haven't developed too many of
the human passions they do have a
tendency to compare against each other
which is going to lead to a lot of
problems but they are relatively happy
relatively healthy but when we
transition to civilized society
everything goes goes down the tubes so
I'm going to civilized society we have
much greater inequalities they end up
being masked by all sorts of social
processes property and laws get
introduced but they don't really help
out the people that they're supposed to
be protecting like the poor or those who
who are vulnerable and human beings in
general become much worse in civilized
society according to Rousseau in moral
terms they're their passions develops so
that they they become obsessed with
having power over other people being
given little distinctions that elevate
them above they're their fellows you
know if you want to put this in
workplace terms think of the person
who's totally obsessed with what their
job title is and you know getting to
control the supply cabinet or something
like that and the resources well that's
what people in civilized society tend to
be like the bosses tend to be jerks the
rest of us tend to be jerks we're all
sort of you know making each other worse
by by our own misery and unhappiness
it's one big ball of human nature having
developed but having developed in bad
ways so what does Wollstonecraft say
about this she says we're so actually
got it wrong how did Rousseau get things
wrong we're looking at each each part of
this first off he's saying you know we
should you know be in a state of nature
that would be great she says we wouldn't
develop our human capacities at all in
that state
what is Rousseau actually thinking but
you know lauding that as the ideal human
beings are supposed to develop we were
given this capacity for self-improvement
so we could actually use it and make
something of ourselves as
and as a species primitive society is
primitive society going to be better
we'll look at that in a moment
what about civilized society so what
Wollstonecraft's says is what we take to
be civilized society isn't really such
it's better to think of it in terms of
let's call it not yet civilized society
where it's actually inheriting a lot of
things from the barbarism that precedes
it it's carrying that stuff through and
if we're going to get any better we
actually have to be a real civilization
which doesn't fully exist at this point
we can say that some societies are more
civilized than others in
Wollstonecraft's times she probably
would be willing to say that in some
respects England where the well the
United States wasn't around quite yet
but if you know if she were able to see
it she would have said that those are
more fitting the mark than say France
France perhaps more than than Germany
Germany definitely more than Russia at
the time you know we could we could
measure this in part by looking at the
development of equality in various
societies today so you know how
civilized is a society it really depends
on the types of equality that have been
built into it so let's look at what she
actually says now in your own words she
says the civilization of the bulk of
people of Europe is very partial it
maybe made a question whether they have
acquired any virtues in exchange for
innocence equivalent to the misery
produced by the vices that have been
plastered over unsightly ignorance and
the free
which has been bartered for splinted
slavery she's saying we're so actually
got it right there's a desire of
dazzling by riches people want to spend
a lot of money to you know be big shots
to have people sucking up to them you
know she talks about sick of fans I mean
suck ups or brown nosers as we call them
these days or your entourage right and
she has many other complicated low
calculations of doting self love have
contributed to overwhelm the mass of
mankind that make Liberty a convenient
handle for my patriotism and she says
Rankin titles are held to be of the
utmost importance so we're living
according to her in a state of not yet
civilized society where people are
obsessed with rank with power with well
with their self-image yeah there's a lot
of inequality still left in there
because these are things that by their
very nature have to be unequal and and
the inequalities that we have with them
can often be quite arbitrary unfair and
when that happens that people are too
happy about it so she says this has been
the wretchedness that has flowed from
hereditary honors riches and monarchy
you know what is Rousseau responding to
her so saying yeah the current situation
really is pretty bad Rousseau was wrong
in thinking that going back to an
original state of nature is prepped and
somehow of the preferable option and
he's also wrong to be lauding primitive
society as she says you know she says
Rousseau celebrates barbarism and he
forgets that in conquering the world the
Romans never dreamed of establishing
their own Liberty on a firm basis or
extending the reigning of virtue so you
know these primitive societies they look
pretty good but if you
to live in them you probably wouldn't be
that happy because when you look at them
carefully
not everybody is free in them a lot of
people are living as slaves a lot of
them are suffering under rather
arbitrary punishments that are coming
from the Lord up on the hill who calls
the shots or the priests that are
telling the people what to do and that
actually carries itself forward into
civilization according to to her she
says that disgusted with artificial
manners and virtues of sort of things
that goes on in modern society the
citizen of Geneva that's her so instead
of properly sifting the subject threw
away the wheat with the chaff
what does that mean we're talking about
throwing the baby away with the
bathwater he throws away civilized
society because of the things that are
wrong with it when it's not yet fully
civilized so instead of looking further
to where it should be going he ends up
saying civilization is no good he should
have asked whether the evils were the
consequence of civilization this sort of
thing or the vestiges the leftovers of
barbarism that's an important question
Wollstonecraft is saying actually what's
going on there is everything that's
wrong with civilized society is just
barbarism that hasn't yet been brought
into the realm of real civilization
which is going to involve genuine
equality and is going to require the
development of virtue where virtue is
going to be the primary mode of
distinction among people so how does she
explain this she says there we go in the
infancy of society when men were just
emerging out of barbarism so at this
point chiefs and priests touching the
most powerful springs of savage conduct
hope and fear must have had unbounded
sway so some people had authority right
and they were
war leaders and they were religious
leaders priests and they fight with each
other for a long time and eventually
somebody wins out and whoever wins out
they're the one who decides you know
what the institutions are gonna look
like how the society is going to be
structured they call the shots they
establish themselves at the apex and
then power flows downward in both kingly
or you know we might say governmental
and priestly or religious hierarchies so
she says an aristocracy is the first
form of government then monarchy and
hierarchy break out of the confusion of
ambitious struggle struggles and the
foundation of both is secured by feudal
tenures so what we have is a feudal
system going on here where there's an
entire set of layering of ranks and
duties and power flows downward from
from the top all the way down to the
people at the bottom we're pretty
miserable
so she says this can't be the case for
too long as we're moving this way the
people acquires some power in the tumult
and that obliges the rulers to gloss
over their oppression with a show of
runt and so far we're here where
Rousseau has been describing in his own
stuff where the the rich the powerful
the the people who have authority create
institutions that seem to be fair that
seem to make a level playing field but
don't actually do so but Wollstonecraft
is saying well that's not the the where
the story should end then why don't you
actually level the playing field if
that's really the case if that's the
problem that it just seems to be a level
playing field but isn't really a level
playing field then fix it and that's
what civilization
will do that's what civilization the
process of civilization will encompass
there's another problem what is it
what's been left out of this entire
picture as we've moved all the way
through here
there's been a class that's been
oppressed that's been subordinated that
has been left out of the picture this
entire time
women inequality exists not in the state
of nature if there is such a thing
because everybody's more or less in the
same you know rude solitary condition at
that time so you don't have any quality
but as soon as we move to primitive
societies if you actually do ethnic
graphical studies and you put aside you
know all these sort of things that we
don't have an awful lot of evidence for
about there being some sort of universal
matriarchy proceeding
you know the shift to patriarchy if you
actually look at the historical stuff
that we've got it looks like most
societies actually have been patriarchal
but what does patriarchy could mean it
means that men regardless of what their
moral condition is are made dominant to
women and there can be like in a women
in higher statuses than lower-class men
but those women are still in some
respect subject to men who are above
them they don't have full rights and
full capacities to develop as human
beings this continues through
civilization
she's faulting guys like Rousseau for
being in certain respects Hippocrates
for talking an awful lot about how you
know bad modern civilized society is
because it introduces even more
inequalities but then wanting to
maintain those very same inequalities
with respect to the relation between men
and women so a few passages are kind of
important to look at with respect to
this so you know she's talking or yeah
she's talking about acquiring manners
before morals as a fundamental problem
and she says that you know women
who are in the upper classes end up
basically just being tokens that are
exchanged they're not treated as full
persons there's got this wonderful
passage riches and hereditary honours
have made ciphers of women to give
consequence to the numerical figure what
does that wonderful phrase mean well a
cipher is like a code or a symbol so
when we talk about riches and hereditary
honors as having a numerical figure what
do we mean there people are able to
compare themselves against others I have
so much in the bank account you have
nothing I have stocks you don't have
stocks we can do the same thing with
with honors women are often treated as
one more commodity that can be not
accumulated unless you you know you're
the harem or something like that but can
be traded can be bought and sold can be
used as a means of exchange and a means
of measure so when we talk about for
example a trophy wife that's exactly
what Wollstonecraft is talking about
they're people essentially purchasing
the affection and the loyalty of another
human being on the basis of their going
to bring to them some more prestige so
she says what this introduces is a kind
of you know ruling and and mastery and
slavery all under the guise of relations
between peoples so she says here we go
I'm this is produced a mixture of
gallantry and despotism into society
which leads the same men we're the
slaves of their mistresses who will do
what women want them to do when they
want to have sex with them when they
want to have them on their arms when
they want to use them as a kind of
conquest to
knives over there sisters wives and
daughters this is only keeping them in
rank-and-file it is true and so what
you're saying there is you know no
matter where we go within society
whatever Stratus that we're at staff
strata or status blended those two words
and know one thing whatever Stratus
women are in an inferior position even
at the upper levels and what are half of
the society right so this should matter
quite a bit but it doesn't seem to
matter to these male social theorists so
she says men have increased that
inferiority of women till women are
almost sunk below the standard of
rational creatures and this gets to one
of the ways in which that inequality is
maintained within not yet civilized
society and will be done away with once
we get to real civilization when women
are treated as irrational or incapable
of developing rationality as we're going
to see in some of the other videos it's
kind of a self-fulfilling prophecy and
you know what's the opposite of that she
says let their faculties have room to
unfold and their virtues to gain
strength then determine where the whole
sex must stand in the intellectual scale
women are not yet ready to be evaluated
because they haven't been allowed to
actually grow and prosper as human
beings freely to develop autonomy to
develop the virtues and intellectual
faculties so she goes on and she she
talks about was a very important past
that she says it's time to effect a
revolution and female manners to restore
to them their lost dignity and to make
them as part of the human species labor
by reforming themselves to reform the
world real civilization is not going to
happen by just changing the political
order so as to give all men the vote if
you don't give women the vote or to
create economic opportunity for men but
not doing so for for women she would say
and she says you know there's going to
be a lot of resist
to this she says I know it will require
a considerable length of time to
eradicate the firmly rooted prejudices
it's going to require some time to
convince women that they act contrary to
their real interest on Ana large-scale
when they cherish or affect weakness
under the name of delicacy and it
convinced the world that the poison
source of female vices and follies in
compliance the custom has been the
sensual homage paid to beauty because
women have been made into essentially
sexual objects or objects of affection
or objects of the male you know gaze and
exchange they've been placed into a
situation over and over and over again
through generations where they're not
able to fully develop and because they
haven't fully developed they don't even
realize yet what they're missing unless
there's somebody like Mary
Wollstonecraft a rather unusual case of
her own time but somebody who we can
recognize as much more common in our own
time where we probably you know if she
were looking at our society she would
have some quibbles with certain things
but she would say on the whole we've
done a pretty good job at aiming that
the fact that more than half of my
college students tend to be female
that's probably a case in point right
there know she's got this other great
thing that she says about the the path
to real civilization and this is what
we'll end with here she says the two
sexes mutually corrupt and improve each
other
this I believe to be an indisputable
truth extending to every virtue she says
all the noble train of virtues on which
social virtue and Happiness are built
should be understood and cultivated by
all mankind or they will be cultivated
to little effect so so long as women are
maintained in a position of inferiority
of subordination in equality that
they're unable to accept with certain
you know very unusual examples break out
of we're not going to be able to make
this transition here from the
civilization that does seem to be rather
barbaric
and doesn't seem to be providing us with
what we actually want and maybe making
us all worse we're not gonna be able to
make the transition to real civilization
so if if we're not going to fix this for
women and we're not going to allow women
to truly develop as they want to and
insist that men do at the same time then
maybe we ought to go back to primitive
Society maybe we'd be better off that
way but if there is the possibility of
moving to real civilization we should
leave this behind and make the
transition that's what she's advising
that's how she thinks inequality will
ultimately be dealt with